I mean sure up here to say I am going to
Europe later this month this is very
exciting for me I've never played
European cities from the 20th to the
27th of this month I will be playing
London Amsterdam Oslo and Stockholm so
I've been boning up on Europe yes check
your local listings there because Europe
is a great town anybody who's ever been
there knows that but one thing I found
studying is that they are worried about
their birth rates their birth rates are
declining I think this is great news
anywhere because I am for less
population but countries tend to get
nervous and anxious when they have less
people than the other countries so they
actually are campaigns to get people to
look at that do it for Denmark that
is a campaign poster that's going on
over there look at what it says has your
bid and Edvin romantic story I don't
have to tell you what that means and we
found it's going on in some other
countries would you like to see the
posters and some of the other oh alright
ah Spain you're at home in bed every
afternoon anyway look at that that's
gonna get people together France pretend
your wife is your mistress
Iceland forget Bjork put on some Barry
White
yeah Russia you know how the Space
Station docks uh Holland there are
better things than your finger and
better places than a dike England mind
the gap
Germany ich bin ein be in her Ireland
tonight get just drunk enough to do it
my people I can make it
Greece try it around the front
and Madison City pretend she's an altar
boy all right
they're not even trying to increase the
population in Vatican City